clairement d'avoir répondu présent à
notre invitation donc monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues madame et
Messieurs nous poursuivons aujourd'hui
nos travaux donc notre commission
d'enquête sur l'efficacité des
politiques publiques en matière de
rénovation énergétique par une table
ronde sur la certification des
entreprises de rénovation énergétique
des bâtiments nous recevons aujourd'hui
les trois organismes qualificateurs
accrédité pour attribuer aux entreprises
la mention RGE l'organisme Qualifelec
représentée par Madame Alexandra de
médico délégué général l'organisme
Qualibat représenté par son Président
Monsieur Gérard senior et par son
directeur général Monsieur
Eric Jost enfin l'organisme QUALITAIRE
représentée par Monsieur Richard Loyen
qui est président de la commission
communication et déléguée aux affaires
publiques et je n'ai pas cité votre nom
monsieur monsieur Teddy Puaud vous êtes
délégué général de cette association
capitaine nerf madame messieurs vous
représentez je l'ai dit ainsi les trois
organismes qui sont accrédités par le
Comité Français d'Accréditation COFRAC
et qui sont chargés d'attribuer aux
entreprises la mention RGE reconnue
garant de l'environnement vous jouez
donc un rôle clé dans la fiabilisation
des travaux de rénovation énergétique
alors que cette mention qui distingue
les professionnels du bâtiment engagés
dans une démarche de qualité et une
condition indispensable pour l'obtention
d'un certain nombre d'aides publiques
lors de nos auditions de nombreux
acteurs de la rénovation énergétique ont
dénoncé les
du label RGE alors que la belle est
censé garantir la compétence de
l'entreprise rénovatrice ces critiques
semblent dénoter une forme de perte de
confiance chez le consommateur dans la
qualité des rénovations et la compétence
des intervenants du côté des
professionnels notamment des artisans la
critique paraît également vive et nous
avons reçu plusieurs témoignages
d'entreprises ayant choisi de faire 100
leur clientèle n'étant pas dépendantes
des subventions pour l'organisation des
travaux globalement d'ailleurs le nombre
d'entreprises certifiées et stable voire
il décroît légèrement
plus généralement et je sais que notre
rapporteur il reviendra l'équilibre
a-t-il aujourd'hui été trouvé entre une
certification
a priori des entreprises et le contrôle
à posteriori de la bonne réalisation des
travaux partagez-vous ces constats quel
bilan faites-vous du label RGE
atteint-il ces objectifs
est-il efficace contre l'écho
délinquance comment peut-on améliorer
l'efficience de la qualification et
redonner confiance dans la rénovation
énergétique enfin quel bilan tirez-vous
de la réforme RGE par l'arrêté du 3 juin
2020 a-t-elle permis cette réforme de
répondre à ces difficultés
avant de vous laisser la parole pour
répondre à cette première question et
pour un propos introductif d'environ 5 à
8 minutes chacun enfin il vous
appartient après de vous distribuer la
parole comme vous le souhaitez il me
revient de vous indiquer que cette
audition est diffusée en direct et en
différé sur le site internet du Sénat et
qu'un compte-rendu sera publié je dois
également vous rappeler qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête serait passible des peines
prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14 et
434-15 du code pénal qui peuvent aller
de trois ans à 7 ans d'emprisonnement et
de 45000 euros à 100000 euros de
d'amende je vous invite donc à tour de
rôle à prêter serment de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité a levé la main
droite et à dire je le jure je vous
propose peut-être de commencer par vous
monsieur le Président et de continuer
jusqu'à monsieur Teddy puo
et bien je vous remercie je vais
maintenant bien sûr vous laisser la
parole ensuite monsieur le rapporteur
complétera mes questions et vous posera
lui-même un certain nombre d'autres
questions et puis nous avons un certain
nombre de nos collègues qui sont
présents membres de la commission
d'enquête et qui pourront également vous
poser un certain nombre de questions
donc je ne sais pas comment vous
souhaiter intervenir si c'est dans
l'ordre tel qu'il est là si madame vous
voulez commencer la première à vous de
décider
alors madame
merci
donc plusieurs questions ont été posées
et ensuite je pense que nous avons
également une série de questions qui va
qui vont permettre d'orienter cette
audition
en propos
introductif
Qualifelec est un organisme de
qualification qui représente les
professionnels du génie électrique
énergétique et numérique nous existons
depuis plus de 60 ans le métier de Kelly
felec c'est la reconnaissance de la
compétence professionnelle de
l'expertise technique du sérieux des
entreprises du monde du bâtiment et plus
particulièrement des métiers
d'électricien la vocation d'un organisme
de qualification c'est d'évaluer sur une
base documentaire la capacité d'une
entreprise avec son personnel
à réaliser des travaux avec dans le
respect des règles de l'art donc ça
c'est premier point
le RGE est venu soutenir le marché de la
rénovation énergétique et Qualifelec a
été autorisé à
porter cette mention RGE en complément
de la qualification métier
des entreprises du génie électrique
énergétique et numérique
le bilan effectivement c'est que vous
parlez de
décoder l'inQuence
c'est un constat qui est fait sur le
marché ça représente une très faible
proportion des entreprises qui ne sont
pas représentatives du monde de la
construction il faut bien le comprendre
et notamment par rapport à l'évolution
des C2E ce qui ressort effectivement
c'est que ce sont des entreprises qui
ont des structures nationales qui
redéfinissent le marché du monde de la
la construction et qui mettent à mal
finalement des professionnels sérieux
qui se retrouvent pas et on le comprend
bien parce que les exigences s'ajoutent
à une qualification professionnelle elle
rajoute des éléments qui sont tout à
fait pertinents mais regarde ces
éléments effectivement il souffre sans
doute d'un manque de visibilité face à
des organismes des entreprises qui ont
d'autres moyens de communication
de la mise en avant des C2E donc il faut
bien comprendre et en respectent tout à
fait le désarroi de ces entreprises qui
ont à cœur de montrer leurs compétences
le système RGE est essentiellement basé
sur des éléments
administratifs la compétence métier et
quelque chose que nous vérifions chez
Qualifelec parce que encore une fois
cette mention RGE s'ajoute à un socle
métier et l'addition de ces éléments
fait que chez Qualifelec à ce jour nous
constatons très peu décodencant dans les
entreprises parmi les entreprises
qualifiées qualifierques avec la mention
RGE
voilà ce que je peux dire par rapport au
premier élément que vous avez évoqué
alors qu'elle est bête c'est une
association qui a été créée en 1949
pour
repérer les entreprises
suffisamment compétentes pour assurer la
reconstruction de du pays
et donc la cette association elle est
constituée par les principales
organisations professionnelles qui
représentent le secteur c'est-à-dire les
entreprises la maîtrise d'oeuvre la
maîtrise d'ouvrage les contrôleurs
techniques et à travers ces différentes
qualifications et certifications
d'artisans et d'entreprise qui ont fait
preuve de leurs compétences et de leur
savoir-faire voilà
alors sur la question directe sur la
qualification RGE
il faut rappeler que quand même pour la
mention RGE et toujours attachée à une
qualification métier comme le disait
Alexandra de médico parce que les
exigences additionnelles du critère RGE
sont d'une part le signe qui est attaché
à un siret donc un établissement il faut
un référent RGE qui est formé fibat ou
ENR et c'est un
référent par rétablissement et on doit
faire un contrôle de réalisation dans
les 24 mois au cours des 24 mois et qui
suivent l'attribution du signe et
d'autre part un second contrôle de la
catégorie de travaux si la carte grise
travaux et considérée comme critique ça
c'est la règle alors quelle est la
procédure pour obtenir
une qualification
il faut choisir son métier je suis
plombier je suis
charpentier je suis plaquiste
constituer un dossier qui comprend un
certain nombre d'éléments très généraux
sur qui concerne les régularités
fiscales juridiques
inscription au métier etc et puis
d'autre part et puis on assurance aussi
on vérifie l'assurance savoir si on a
communication du chiffre d'affaires des
effectifs et une partie technique qui
atteste des compétences le personnel les
références de chantier les attestations
de clients etc et cette compitude de
dossiers elle est vérifiée par kalibat
ça c'est notre métier de qualificateur
ensuite le dossier est ensuite soumis à
une commission d'examen
cette commission d'examen qui est
constituée de professionnels des
entrepreneurs des artisans qualifiés des
mètres d'ouvrage public ou autre des
bailleurs sociaux ou des architectes des
bureaux d'études des contre la technique
des assureurs donc on a une l'ensemble
de la filière qui représente et c'est
cette commission là qui est l'instance
de décision d'attribution de la
qualification et du de la mention Hergé
nous avons 130 commissions nous sommes
répartis sur l'ensemble du territoire et
on a 2700 membres bénévoles qui
assistent à ces commissions
alors quelle est la spécificité de notre
organisme on a 35 agences dans le
territoire en métropole et à la Réunion
160 personnes
c'est 130 commission départementale sont
à la fois départementales et nationales
il y a les deux et tous les dossiers de
demande qualification et les rapports
sont examinés par ces commissions voilà
la Constitution
de comment on devient RGE chez
moi
alors troisième donc
qualité énergies renouvelables
merci de nous donner la parole dans on
est plus jeune on est né en 2006
avec le nerplan Syndicat des
professionnels du solaire la CAPEB la
FFB et à l'époque pour prendre en main
la gestion de calisson qui avait été
créé par l'ADEME en 99 qui était la
première entre guillemets Marc pour
distinguer les professionnels compétents
pour installer des chauffe-eau solaires
sauf que l'ADEME son métier c'est pas de
gérer des qualifications et donc elle
s'est fait déborder par le nombre et
elle nous a demandé en tant
qu'organisation professionnelle va de
prendre notre avenir en main et à ce
moment-là on est tendu le champ de nos
qualifications au bois énergie à la
pompe à chaleur à la géothermie au
photovoltaïque et plus récemment jusqu'à
la recherche électrique donc pour les
voitures électriques donc aujourd'hui
c'est 18000 entreprises pour à peu près
30 000 qualifications actives
RGE et pas forcément la panacée mais
aujourd'hui quand même un bon outil
c'est pour ça que je m'inscris un peu en
faux par rapport au constat qui a été
dressé un peu acrimonieux contre le
dispositif RJE
il nous permet aujourd'hui de recevoir
des récriminations de clients qui sont
pas contents et parce qu'ils sont pas
contents de leur entreprise et ce qui
nous permet de nous apercevoir que
l'entreprise est pas forcément qualifiée
chez nous elle a pu notre marque donc ça
c'est des choses c'est pas notre
quotidien mais c'est régulièrement on a
cabinet d'avocat qui travaille à mettre
en demeure des entreprises pour dire
vous utilisez frauduleusement vous
n'êtes pas qualifié etc mais si
l'entreprise est qualifiée chez nous et
qu'elle a mal travaillé on peut faire un
audit et on peut suspendre l'entreprise
de sa qualification RGE donc on a
quelque part un système qualité où on
fait une promesse de satisfaction client
s'il est pas content il a le droit de se
plaindre légitimement et on va instruire
ça demande alors après voilà aujourd'hui
on ne reçoit des plaintes d'entreprises
qui n'ont jamais été qualifiées
qui ont été qualifiés mais qu'on a
suspendu ou radié et très très peu
d'entreprises qui sont aujourd'hui du
manque qualifié et quand la plainte est
justifiée après un contrôle et un audit
la main ne tremble pas on la suspend
voir jusqu'à la radiation c'est prévue
dans nos règlements
juste pour prouver l'intérêt des jeux
par rapport à pas d'air ge c'est le
footballtaïque avant 2017 il y avait pas
de RGE pour le photovoltaïque et pas
d'exigence n'importe qui pouvait faire
n'importe quoi donc on avait des
pizzaiolo qui se transformaient en
installateur solaire on a tout vu dans
ce boum du photovoltaïque et résultat
aujourd'hui c'est les professionnels qui
sont compétents qui travaillent bien etc
qui ont des problèmes pour s'assurer qui
payent des polices d'assurance fort cher
parce qu'on a laissé faire n'importe
quoi n'importe qui avant depuis 2017
depuis qu'il y a l'exigence RGE pour
bénéficier de la prime à
l'autoconsommation et de la vente de
surplus on a assaini le marché
aujourd'hui enfin je dirais les échos
délin qu'on est en plus un secteur qui
est contrôlé de façon récurrente parce
qu'on a été mis sous observations
par la QC maintenant on a un audit tous
les 14 installations finalement voilà un
marché où les échos délinquants ont
lancé vite parce que personne n'est
contrôlait mais depuis qu'il y a des
contrôles récurrents ils ont deserté le
marché ils sont allés ailleurs dans
l'isolation en euros voilà mais ils sont
maintenant ils reviennent un peu pas
forcément en mettant RGE en vendant de
l'autoconsommation totale on voit à ce
moment là il y a pas besoin d'être RGE
et ils demandent pas d'aide entre
guillemets parce qu'on a un marché qui
gagne en maturité l'intérêt RGE et de
l'instruction qui est faite par les
équipes d'instructeurs de qualiténer
c'est également détecter des signaux
faibles décodélinquance deux que je
voudrais porter à votre connaissance des
faux centres de formation qui étaient
liées à des échos délinquants
on s'en aperçu comment parce que il
faisait des fours en écriture avec le
même formateur que nous on avait
agrémenté mais il faisait des formations
deux endroits en même temps un dans un
vrai centre de formation un dans un faux
centre de formation et centres de
formation il se tempait mais vous avez
réussi l'examen RGE alors qu'il y avait
jamais eu de session de formation donc
ça ça nous a permis d'engager des
poursuites de faire
suspendre ces centres de formation alors
que c'était des machines à tampon pour
dire qu'on y avait des gens qui étaient
compétents pour rentrer j'ai aussi dire
l'attractivité de la marque
l'autre s'il nous faible détecter
récemment le stagiaire clone
c'est la même personne qui va suivre des
formations mais jamais avec la même
identité alors à chaque fois l'examen
depuis le temps qui fait les formations
mais il le fait pour quelqu'un d'autre
pour semper monsieur Dupont un jour
Monsieur Ahmed le lendemain monsieur
Sanchez le troisième formation donc ce
qui veut dire que pour nous on travaille
avec les pouvoirs publics pour qu'on y
voit nos centres de formation maintenant
on exige la carte d'identité quand il
faut passer l'examen c'est pas des
choses qui étaient usuelles dans les
pratiques parce qu'on ne pensait pas que
ça allait aller jusque là donc voilà RGE
c'est pas forcément la perfection c'est
un système qui a parfaire mais néanmoins
il nous permet de pouvoir intervenir
s'il y a des clients qui sont fait léser
par une entreprise qualifiée ça peut
exister il y a beaucoup de gens qui
gravitent autour en se prétendant RJ qui
ne le sont pas et c'est avec les
pouvoirs publics qu'on doit lutter
contre ces entreprises ou c'est elle qui
font du mal au secteur et puis tout ce
que je dis sur les signaux faibles avec
les gens qui essaient d'avoir des fonds
tampons pour se prétendre RGE faire vite
des affaires et partir demain
je vais laisser la parole à notre
rapporteur est-ce que vous pouvez
simplement peut-être rappeler la
différence entre qualification et
certification
non il y a pas de
oui la différence entre une
qualification et une certification c'est
que généralement la qualification et les
sous un régime d'accréditation qui à ce
jour est la norme
nfx5091 normes qui ne sera plus utilisée
par le coffrage si possible la question
de nos accréditations qui vont tomber en
fin d'année c'est un sujet
urgent important et les certifications
qui sont sur le périmètre de la norme
qui est une isoen 17 0,65 donc dans le
domaine de RG vous avez des
qualifications et vous avez aussi des
certifications
là les trois nous délivrons des
qualifications sur la base de la norme
NFX ce sont des qualifications RGE et
nous avons également chez Qualibat une
certification offre globale de
rénovation qui est livré par notre
service certibat et qui est dans le
périmètre de la 17065
je vous remercie de cette précision
monsieur le rapporteur
oui merci merci madame la Présidente
merci pour déjà vos premières vos
premières explications peut-être juste
rappeler sur le cadre de notre
commission de notre commission d'enquête
c'est vrai que la question du bas de la
qualité des travaux puisque quand on se
penche sur la question des politiques
publiques qui sont mis en place pour
pour développer en tout cas aller plus
vite sur la question de la rénovation
thermique c'est sûr que se pose tout de
suite la question de la qualité de ces
de ces travaux et donc tout ce qui peut
être autour de des différentes
qualifications du contrôle également et
donc c'est vrai que du coup ce label RGE
au centre en tout cas de nos de nos
réflexions puisque c'est vrai que quand
on à la fois avec ma prime rénove etc on
réoriente des gens justement sur ces
qualifications là et donc on doit
s'assurer effectivement que ça
fonctionne et en tout cas quels sont
garantes quatre qualités de qualité de
travaux moi j'avais peut-être déjà une
première question enfin précision par
rapport à vos différents organismes
entre Qualibat catalytelec enfin
sur une entreprise on va dire qui fait
l'entreprise générale qui fait
l'ensemble qu'elle soit de l'électricité
de la plomberie de la rénovation
thermique etc
en fait quel type de qualification enfin
quel type de RGE elle doit avoir quoi en
gros si je précise est-ce que une
entreprise générale qui a son RGE en
électricité par exemple ou sur les e NR
enfin peu importe est-ce que ça suffit
en tout cas pour ensuite appliquer et
faire l'ensemble des travaux
c'est-à-dire d'isolation etc sans avoir
de d'ouvriers spécialisés sur cette sur
ce sujet là
alors ça va dépendre du domaine de
compétence des différents organismes
qualificateurs chez kalibat on a tous
les métiers du bâtiment sauf les
électriciens qui sont donc chez califec
mais après une entreprise une
qualification
tout court d'État n'existe pas ça va
être des qualifications par métier et
après les qualifications métiers elles
permettent d'être RGE dans une catégorie
de travaux rgu et les catégories de
travaux Ege elles sont déterminées par
le décret du 3 juin 2020 donc ça veut
dire qu'en gros une entreprise
peut faire appel effectivement donc
forcément si elle est entreprise
générale qui est électricité devra faire
appel à qualité avec pour la partie
électricité ensuite à vous parce que
vous faites le fin voilà en fonction des
des besoins mais devra répondre à
l'ensemble des catégories en fait on
peut avoir effectivement un plombier qui
électricien qui pour la partie catégorie
de travaux radiateurs
émetteur électrique va être rjo chez
Qualifelec et pour la partie
isolation thermique par l'intérieur
parce que il fait des salles de bains il
va être chez kalibat ça peut arriver
merci déjà pour savoir pour ces pour ces
précisions non non sinon de manière plus
plus peut-être plus générale sur la sur
la question face sur la conformité en
tout cas sur le sur le résultat parce
que c'est vrai que du coup on a des
entreprises
qui ont leur
ge qui fait confiance en tout cas les
personnes qui vont faire confiance et
c'est vrai que sur les différentes
études qu'on a pu qu'on a pu avoir alors
elles sont il y en a beaucoup en fait
dire de que ça soit sur Que Choisir il y
avait un rapport du CGEDD la qui avait
été fait je crois il y a un an à peu
près
et qui avec des retours quand même sur
des des faibles taux de conformité en
tout cas sur que ça soit sur l'isolation
que ça soit fin sur les travaux qui sont
qui sont réalisés
et donc ils peuvent justement poser
question quoi de se dire on a justement
ce label RGE et puis derrière quand on a
fait des contrôles quand on regarde la
réalisation des travaux on n'est on n'a
pas le résultat en tout cas escompté et
c'est ce que disait aussi madame c'est
que du coup ça ça se répercute en fait
sur toute la profession puisque quand on
a quelques entreprises qui du coup sont
défaillantes ben effectivement ça va ça
va rejaillir sur l'ensemble de la de la
profession et donc ma question elle
était plutôt savoir si il manque que
justement plus de ce que ça c'était ce
qui est souligné dans pas mal de
rapports de contrôle à posteriori et
d'ailleurs il y a pas mal d'entreprises
qui plaident pour justement avoir
beaucoup plus de contrôle
en fin de travaux en fin de chantier
pour que pour justement garantir et que
les entreprises qui font bien leur
boulot ben voilà ça soit ça soit validé
et puis que celles qui le font moins
bien en tout cas soit mis de elles
soient mis de côté et donc je voulais
savoir si du coup il y avait à la fois
des réflexions ce que vous ce que vous
pensiez en fait de cette de cet aspect
là
ce qui me fait peut-être dire aussi que
vous avez dit qualité de que vous aviez
peut-être moins de problématique en tout
cas sur votre secteur est-ce que c'est
lié par exemple au consuel et c'est à
dire que est-ce qu'il y a une démarche
du coup de consuel qui est dans
profession déjà intégrée en tout cas et
donc de se dire toute façon il y aura un
contrôle fin de chantier et je devrais
être conforme et donc du coup c'est déjà
quelque chose qui est intégré et
derrière du coup c'est ma question c'est
que c'est vrai que on a eu pas mal de
retour je crois quand on avait reçu les
représentants de DF qui justement
proposait en tout cas à orienter en
disant en s'appuyant sur le consuel et
en se disant est-ce que il ne pourrait
pas y avoir un dispositif qui pourrait
ressembler au consuel sur d'autres
aspects du chantier et mais forcément du
coup avec un contrôle après travaux et
qui vient garantir en fait la qualité
des travaux donc je voulais avoir votre
votre votre avis là dessus en tout cas
savoir et puis aussi ce qu'on a pu avoir
certains qui nous disent en fait ben
justement cette labellisation en fait
elle est pas
tellement efficiente en fait en tout cas
garantie pas totalement une qualité de
travaux
et ce qu'on a vu aussi et qui est quand
même confirmé quand on a rencontré aussi
les représentants de différentes
entreprises en disant et puis la
présidente l'a rappelé le nombre de RGE
est stable voire en baisse et qu'on a
plutôt des
entreprises souvent de qualité qui ne
font pas qui font le choix délibérés de
ne pas aller vers le RGE parce que
j'estime à la fois de pas en avoir
besoin et que ce sont pas forcément les
moins bonnes entreprises quoi et donc
voilà ce lien en tout cas entre le label
et puis du coup la qualité et des
entreprises qui se disent à la rigueur
qui sont qui s'en détournent en tout cas
et ça c'est vrai qu'on a pas mal vu
remonter et donc ce ce savoir si voilà
si se dire est-ce que ce principe d'un
label qui du pouvez définir en disant
bah voilà les travaux sont très très
bien réalisés et le contrôle a postéori
à la rigueur sans label et te dire bah
voilà à partir du moment les travaux
sont bien faits je dirais quel que soit
ça définit toute façon la qualité de
l'entreprise et c'est quand même ce
qu'on souhaite quoi donc un peu votre
avis là-dessus et je sais que c'est
pratiqué je crois que c'est en Allemagne
où il y a plutôt ce système de contrôle
après coup savoir aussi si vous avez
peut-être des des avis sur ce qui peut
se faire dans d'autres pays en tout cas
des retours sur ce qui peut se faire
dans d'autres pays sur justement la
qualité des travaux voilà merci
alors il est important de
pour nous Qualibat on va vous donner nos
statistiques parce qu'on a une
convention avec l'État qui nous oblige à
faire un rapport annuel et on a
aujourd'hui on a sur les 56 000
entreprises qui sont qualifiées chez
nous on a 44000 environ professionnel RG
sur ces 44000 professionnels RGE comme
je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure on a des
auditeurs qui vont auditer les chantiers
et donc on a 16000 audits par an
les dernières statistiques c'est de 2022
c'est 16000 audits on a 83%
d'audit sans non conformité
ensuite on a 9% environ de
non-conformités mineurs donc on est à
92% de travaux qui sont de qualité
pour nos chantiers pour nos entreprises
qualifiées
qui est tout mélanger dans les
discussions et de ce qu'on entend un
petit peu discussion de comptoir et
autres sur le RGE c'est en mélange le
RGE le C2E m'imprime rénov et tout ça et
c'est pas la même chose
mais ces deux œufs c'est un produit
financier
il y a des industriels du C2E qui
ont monté leur business plan là-dessus
on va chercher les aides et notamment ce
qui a
beaucoup endommagé la réputation en
général des travaux c'est les travaux à
1 €, il y a des échos délinquants qui se
sont mis sur ce marché là parce qu'il
suffisait en plus on avait un public de
précaire on leur dit bah c'est un euro
bien sûr et puis les travaux ne sont pas
forcément bien faits en général les
contrôles C2E ce ne sont pas les
contrôleursge nous on a une grille qui
est bien qui a été bien établie on
arrive même avec l'ensemble des
organisés et c'est grillages elles sont
dans le décret et un audit de RGE n'a
rien à voir un contrôle C2E contrôle C2E
va comparer la surface on va voir s'il y
a s'il y a des travaux des fois on
contrôle pas parce que les entreprises
elles ont soufflé de de l'isolant dans
un dans un comble elles ont enlevé 4 tu
elles ont soufflé ça là-dedans et puis
hop on referme et on peut plus contrôler
voilà et donc c'est ce mélange là qui
est dans le dans le
colportage habituel sur le RGE voilà les
résultats que nous avons c'est ça 16000
audits je n'ai pas dit aussi on a 300
réclamations par an 300 réclamations par
an ce qui est très peu et 300 bruts
après on travaille mais le particulier
qui est pas content il nous envoie un
courrier et on instruit son dossier et
puis on est suivi par le coffrage il dit
bah voilà vous avez tel qu'est-ce que
vous avez répondu voilà et on voit la le
décalage entre le nombre de réclamations
que nous recevons tout est ouvert on a
un service pour ça et puis la quantité
de chantier que nous avons et il ne
faudrait pas que
les politiques publiques
s'oriente sur de la répression la
sanction et autres qui va embêter 92% de
bons acteurs des artisans qui déjà
trouvent que c'est compliqué que bon et
puis laissez-nous travailler plutôt que
nous demander des choses et puis en plus
on va rajouter du contrôle on va
rajouter de la sanction qui ne va pas
dans le sens de la montée en compétence
de de la filière qui est déjà bien bien
élevé et que nous en tant qu'organisme
de qualification on est dans un
écosystème avec les organisations
professionnelles lorsqu'on repère un
certain nombre de choses qui de
non-conformité on le dit à nos
administrateurs elle fait capable et que
avec leurs organisations que de les
organismes de formation
monte en compétences leur leurs oreilles
voilà
je voulais réagir sur plusieurs points
le premier c'est effectivement déjà se
rappeler la la conditionnalité des aides
au fait que l'entreprise soit RGE
c'était déjà un grand pas en avant il
faut se souvenir que il y a pas si
longtemps que ça on conditionnait les
aides simplement en fait que le matériel
soit qualité indépendamment du
professionnel qui intervenait pour le
poser bon on a parlé des pizzaiolo mais
mais sans dénigrer une profession plus
qu'une autre on voyait une inadéquation
en tout cas entre les le professionnel
qui pouvait intervenir et celui qui en
avait réellement la capacité et ce mot
capacité est important puisque c'est
justement ce qui ce qui est visé par la
qualification c'est la capacité d'une
entreprise à réaliser une prestation
donnée sa définition normative et cette
capacité elle se traduit par le contrôle
d'un certain nombre d'exigences qui dans
le RJ ont été renforcés par rapport à la
norme existante chez organicalification
notamment avec l'introduction de cette
obligation de présence d'un référent
technique et d'un audit après
la qualification de l'entreprise
et ça c'est important parce que vérifier
les moyens en tout cas la capacité
d'entreprise à réaliser une prestation
donnée c'est aussi tirer une filière
vers le haut en vérifiant que les
entreprises qui interviennent dans un
domaine donné vous l'aurez compris on
est qualifié RGE mais pour un domaine
donné on n'est pas qualifié un jeu pour
pour faire tout type de travaux c'est
par rapport à un domaine bien précis on
est qualifié par exemple pour les pompes
à chaleur on va être qualifié pour le
solaire thermique et tous les autres
travaux qui existent
mais on peut pas tout faire avec une
seule qualification on va donc vérifier
que l'entreprise est assurée pour
installer des pompes à chaleur on va
vérifier que l'entreprise du personnel
ayant des connaissances sur la pompe à
chaleur contrairement au travers du
référent technique et la réalité c'est
que les dossiers qu'on reçoit sont
rarement bons du premier coup et donc
une entreprise qui entreprend une
démarche de qualification va devoir
effectivement s'assurer qu'on ne l'est
pas aller en formation quand les
personnes ne sont pas formées à des
systèmes qui dans notre cas sont
nécessaires nouveau par rapport à la
profession tous les tous les plombiers
chauffagistes n'ont pas suivi dans leur
cursus initiaux de formation sur
l'installation de pompe à chaleur c'est
pas vrai et d'ailleurs on constate au
travers des formations des référents
techniques un taux d'échec qui n'est pas
neutre et des formations qui pour avoir
assisté à un certain nombre d'entre
elles nécessitent de mobiliser un peu
d'énergie pour les professionnels
présents pour assimiler les différentes
thématiques abordées
hydrauliques froid électricité et des
dimensionnement qui vont un petit peu
plus loin que ce qu'on est habitué à
faire notamment pour l'installation de
chaudière gaz
bref la qualification une fois que la
vérifié ses moyens qu'elle a permis de
tirer vers le haut une filière avec un
socle minimum d'attendu pour les
intervenants dans un monde donné ça veut
pas dire qu'on va garantir le résultat
et c'est peut-être là où il y a une
déception de la part de certains
particuliers qui pourraient y voir une
garantie du résultat on est vraiment sur
les moyens on peut imaginer que
quelqu'un qui sait faire qui a la
capacité de faire et qui met du bon
matériel devrait obtenir un bon résultat
néanmoins on a quand même des contrôles
qui sont faits et qui vont pas du tout
dans le sens de de ce qui peut être
colporté et là-dessus je suis assez
d'accord avec kalibat ce qu'on mesure
concrètement au travers d'audit fait par
des organismes de contrôle eux aussi à
créditer dans le domaine de l'inspection
donc c'est le métier qui sont
indépendants qui s'appuie sur une grille
de contrôle qui est bien plus étoffée
que celle qui existe dans l'inspection
ces deux œufs
ce qu'on constate c'est que globalement
il y a peu d'écart aujourd'hui on
constate nous à qualité nerf entre 80 et
85 % d'installation qui te présente pas
d'écart ou quelques écarts j'ai mineur
donc la très grande majorité des
installations ne présentent pas d'écart
et celles qui en présente sont corrigés
donc on est bien dans une logique
d'amélioration continue on a vérifié que
la personne avait capacité et si elle
fait des erreurs elle est corrige si
elle est corrige pas elle est suspendue
automatiquement et donc retirer des
dispositifs et les entreprises qui font
des écarts
importants sont systématiquement
réédités
d'amélioration continue mais on va
vérifier que cette erreur ne se
reproduit pas et si elle était amenée à
se reproduire il faudrait corriger à
nouveau et dans notre cas je crois que
c'est la pratique désormais tous les
organismes de qualification on
demanderait à ce que le référent
technique retourne en formation puisque
vraisemblablement il y a des lacunes si
on constate de façon répétée qu'il y a
des écarts majeurs au travers des
installations qu'on va auditer
concernant le RGE et son développement
je pense qu'on a des réalités un peu
différentes en fonction des domaines et
peut-être aussi des dispositifs
incitatifs qui ont pu évoluer dans le
temps et en tout cas concernant les
énergies renouvelables nous nous avons
nous enregistrons une croissance
constante depuis la mise en place du RGE
2012 et aujourd'hui on a une croissance
qui tous les ans
est présente et en réalité même si
accéléré au cours des dernières années
et
je crois qu'on a plus que multiplié par
deux le nombre de demandes reçues par
nos services
et
on a un afflux de nouvelles entreprises
et forcément si on a des nouvelles
d'entreprise on repart pour certaines
sur le début de la courbe
d'apprentissage des entreprises qui vont
à nouveau faire des erreurs et qu'on va
aider à corriger et on voit d'ailleurs
que les entreprises qui sont là depuis
plus longtemps au moins des cas que les
autres puisqu'elles ont appris de leurs
erreurs ça aussi c'est important parce
qu'on a vraiment une machine qui qui
tire vers le haut effectivement plus on
fera de contrôle tout en
gardant
comment dire un peu de sans tomber dans
les excès de tout contrôler mais en tout
cas plus on se rend capacité de réaliser
des contrôles rapidement et puis on aura
cette capacité à tirer les entreprises
nouvelles dans le dispositif vers le
haut en
identifiant en pointant du doigt là où
il y a des écarts et en leur permettant
d'améliorer leur pratique sur les
réclamations de la même manière que nos
camarades de kalibat nous enregistrons
pour notre part nous aussi très peu de
réclamations
sauf erreur de ma part je pourrais
vérifier dans le rapport mais c'est
moins de 2% des entreprises qualifiées
qui ont fait l'objet de réclamation donc
on nous explique que tout va mal mais en
réalité aujourd'hui n'importe quel
particulier peut aller sur le site
de France rénov et dépose une
réclamation il peut aussi venir
directement vers nos services et quand
on collecte tout ça infini sur une année
c'est moins de 2% des professionnels qui
font l'objet de réclamation et faire
l'objet d'une incarnation ça veut pas
dire forcément qu'on a fait une bêtise
puisque dans les réclamations qu'on est
amené à traiter à l'amiable qui est
particulier on constate aussi des
installations qui ont été faites
correctement mais où il peut y avoir des
difficultés on va dire relationnelles
entre le client et l'entreprise il est
vrai néanmoins que les statistiques sur
les audites soient signalement des
audits qu'on va diligenter en plus des
audits classiques dans le cadre de la
qualification les résultats sont
globalement moins bons que ce qu'on peut
constater sur les audits on va dire de
manière aléatoire dans le cadre de la
qualification
puisque je crois qu'on est à un audit
sur deux qui présente un écart-mageur
versus tout à l'heure je vous l'ai dit
environ 20%
donc effectivement il faut prendre un
peu de recul par rapport à ce brouha qui
nous dit que tout va mal tout va pas si
mal bien au contraire on a un dispositif
qui tire vers le haut la profession
est-ce qu'il faut renforcer les critères
on peut l'étudier ce qu'on peut étudier
aussi c'est comment on peut fiabiliser
des contrôles qui sont faits on a dans
notre cas on vous le décrit tout à
l'heure un des publics qui sont agiles
pour essayer de passer au travers des
critères existants c'est qui sont pas si
mauvais quand on essaie de contourner un
critère existant c'est que concrètement
il est irritant pour ceux qui essaient
de le contourner on vous donnait
l'exemple du contrôle pour la formation
mais on a un certain nombre de critères
plus on aura cette capacité à aller
chercher l'information à la source
collecte des références par exemple
auprès du pnc2e des choses qui se
mettent en place qui sont mis en place
très récemment c'est une bonne chose si
on peut fluidifier ce process là c'est
ça va dans le bon sens
essayer d'aller chercher l'information à
la source sur les assurances pour être
aussi un moyen de
fiabiliser en tout cas la le contrôle
que la police d'assurance n'a pas été
modifiée par le professionnel on a des
axes comme ça qui peuvent être
travaillés pour on va dire vraiment
éviter les tentatives de faux qu'on
constate qu'on constate parfois même sur
des documents assez
surprenants les statuts les statuts
c'est la main de l'entreprise peut
modifier ces statuts lors des poser on
constate néanmoins qu'il y a des
professionnels qui nous envoient des
fausses statues pour justifier d'une
activité dans un domaine qui n'ont pas
arrêté sur les statuts initiaux donc il
y a un enjeu effectivement de continuer
à accompagner la filière et je pense que
il y a des choses sur lesquelles on
pourrait être aidé sur
faciliter la collecte des documents ou
des informations à la source et pourquoi
pas imaginer des contrôles
supplémentaires mais
il faut être vigilant à pas punir non
plus des professionnels qui
on le voit à force d'être audité en
réalité ont des résultats très positifs
et donc on il faut pas punir ceux qui
font déjà bien
je voulais juste ajouter au niveau de
qualité NR on a réussi à industrialiser
le contrôle qualité des installations
d'énergie renouvelables qui étaient
quelque chose qui n'existait pas et pas
de référentiel qu'on a commencé donc
l'année dernière c'était quasiment 14000
audits qui ont été réalisés à 80% qui
sont bons
l'échange de données avec le pnc2e est
vraiment important parce que ça peut
nous permettre d'aller contrôler des
installations qui aujourd'hui nous ne
sont pas déclarés par des entreprises
donc l'entreprise rentre dans la calife
elle fait des chantiers elle nous le dit
pas donc nous on peut pas aller
contrôler sauf si le client se plaint
alors que si on savait que l'entreprise
Tartempion elle a fait x installation on
pourrait aller contrôler donc ça
aujourd'hui sans cet échange de données
on peut pas et par ailleurs le contrôle
tous les bons pour choper quelques
mauvais ça peut coûter aussi cher etc
donc on aura aussi besoin d'avoir une
taxe force sur contre l'écho délinquance
avec les services de l'État
parce que aujourd'hui un organisme de
qualification professionnelle c'est pas
le fisc on n'a pas de pouvoir de
contrôle on n'est pas la répression des
fraudes et aujourd'hui si on pouvait
plus facilement travailler ensemble pour
signaler un tel entreprise parce qu'on a
beaucoup de retour il y a aujourd'hui la
pub sur Internet peut-être moi j'ai vu
que j'ai un moteur de
trahi par mes cookies mais je peux pas
lire un journal sans que j'ai de la pub
décoderlinquants en ligne ils font même
de la guitare les pub mais les vidéos
YouTube des nerfs plans avec écouter
nous cinq minutes on va vous faire
économiser 80% sur la facture alors que
c'est jamais plus de 40% donc
aujourd'hui on a besoin d'agir contre
cela parce que ils agissent en tout
impunité pour berner le français moyen
entre guillemets pour récupérer son
adresse lui envoyer un commercial donc
voilà c'est des choses et puis renforcer
également le
l'information des consommateurs c'est
que nous côtés Enerplan on va travailler
Kylie Jenner pour sortir une autre
juridique pour que le français qui tombe
dans la main de l'écho délinquants qui
lui a vendu l'installation au solaire
fort cher il puisse s'en dédire jusqu'à
14 jours à la livraison du matériel chez
lui
donc ça veut dire qu'entre le moment il
a commandé et le moment on va lui livrer
matin les 14 jours après il peut se
défaire de sa commande et ça il faut le
faire savoir entre guillemets aux
Français et c'est pas parce qu'ils ont
signé sauf s'il a acheté sur foire
malheureusement mais dans tous les
autres cas il peut quand même se
dépatouiller donc n'achetez pas sur foie
jamais
et pour le reste on va donner les outils
pour que les consommateurs puissent se
défendre eux aussi contre les aigrefins
[Musique]
est-ce que vous voulez rajouter quelque
chose le niveau de qualifec oui
volontiers merci alors
Qualifelec ne représente que 12% de
certificats RGE par rapport à la
totalité de des certificats qualifiés
donc nous sommes bien conscients que
nous sommes pas les mieux placés pour
porter un et de vous donner un avis sur
le fonctionnement du label RGE et de ces
deux œufs néanmoins
Qualifelec dans son activité aujourd'hui
des livres 5000 certificats Hierve dans
un contexte réglementaire et à ce jour
au niveau de la délivrance des
certificats irve on n'a pas de non
conformité et on n'a pas dû radier une
entreprise suite à une réclamation ou
une plainte ou un audit
en ce qui concerne la partie RJ
néanmoins qui est le sujet des bornes de
recharge véhicules électriques
infrastructures de recharge pour
véhicules électriques excusez-moi
en ce qui concerne la partie RGE à ce
jour on a 1667 entreprises qui sont
qualifiées avec une mention RGE sur 2022
on a effectué 800 audits de performance
contre le réalisation on a eu trois donc
conformités qui ont été levés
après la production du rapport d'audit
et ça n'a engendré aucune suspension
d'irradiation donc à ce jour
les chiffres que vous évoquez on ne les
a pas à l'échelle de Qualifelec et on
n'a pas de retour de l'ADEME de ces non
conformités majeurs qui posent problème
sur le marché on a que les chiffres de
qualiflec que l'on fournit chaque année
à la DGC à la DHP et à l'ADEME madame
vous parliez ou monsieur excusez-moi
vous parliez de l'Allemagne
l'Allemagne il faut comprendre que pour
créer une entreprise l'accès aux métiers
est encadré avec une production de
diplômes
aujourd'hui un boulanger ce qui était
évoqué tout à l'heure peut créer une
entreprise dans le monde de la
construction c'est pour ça que le rôle
de Qualifelec et des organismes de
qualification est justement d'analyser
sur une base documentaire différence
entre qualification et certification la
qualification est une revue documentaire
qui est gérée par les pairs donc par des
professionnels qui ont
toute liberté pour demander les éléments
complémentaires et s'assurer que sur un
examen
documentaire le profil en personnel
fait la démonstration de la compétence
métier
cette compétence va se faire sur la base
de CV diplômes et d'une analyse complète
de l'écosystème de l'entreprise et cette
analyse documentaire il faut comprendre
que c'est quelque chose qui est adapté
au monde du bâtiment
un système de certification pas
envisageable pour le monde du bâtiment
parce que tout complexe et trop sur la
notion de service aujourd'hui en France
on a cette chance d'avoir des
entreprises de structures artisanales et
qui a fait que en qualifie beaucoup
qui qui ont à cœur cette indépendance et
le côté certification serait trop
intrusif et encore une fois l'analyse de
l'écosystème d'une entreprise sur une
base documentaire portée par les Pères
fait que le système fonctionne à
l'échelle de qualifier lac donc ça c'est
un point important donc se contenter
entre guillemets d'un contrôle
n'empêcherait pas tout le marché et même
libérerait encore plus
l'accès et effectivement à un moment
donné il y aurait peut-être le constat
mais ça serait toujours à posteriori le
contrôle a posteriori n'est valable
que si on encadre l'accès au marché et
le système de qualification aujourd'hui
c'est ce qu'il le permet donc ça c'est
un point important après oui contrôle
aléatoire vous avez évoqué consuel chez
les électriciens encore une fois je
parle de ce que je connais
deux électriciens ont l'habitude de
subir des contrôles
de réaliser des audits de sur la
sécurité et la conformité aux normes
donc le métier des électriciens est
normé c'est un constat et ils ont
l'habitude d'être contrôlées par le
consuel ou des bureaux de contrôle quand
ils sont sur des marchés
orientés tertiaires
ce contrôle est basé sur la sécurité sur
le respect des règles de l'art il n'est
pas basé sur la performance ce que
vérifie les audits les contrôles de
réalisation qui sont après coup c'est
également la performance on pourrait
très bien donner mission à des
organismes de contrôle
de rajouter cette notion de de
performance
et peut-être faire qui aurait qu'un seul
système de contrôle unique pour pour le
solaire photovoltaïque chez califelec on
ne fait appel qu'à consuel pour le
contrôle de performance qui vient
s'ajouter
dans le cadre de leur contrôle de
sécurité ce qu'on regrette à l'échelle
de califelec dans cette cette
arrêtée qui date de 2018 qui est à part
2017 on l'a validé en 2018 à part qui
est différent de la rénovation
énergétique c'est bien l'arrêter
autoconsommation pour justement que le
particulier puisse bénéficier d'un tarif
de rachat le consuel a une mission pour
vérifier la sécurité selon un système de
contrôle qu'il maîtrise qui est à
hauteur de 20% des installations mais
c'est lui qui a la volumétrie c'est Lui
qui connaît la ation d'électricien
on a demandé qualife a demandé à consuel
de faire ces 7% de d'audit de
performance encore une fois
consuel quand il arrive sur sur un
chantier si l'installation n'est pas en
sécurité il va refuser l'injection
réseau si l'installation n'est pas
performante il va nous renvoyer un
rapport
avec des non conformités mais il va pas
empêcher le professionnel de continuer
et il va rester sur sa volumétrie des
20% et il va continuer à faire 7% sur la
performance c'est après à qualifierlec
d'aller au charbon entre guillemets
d'aller au front pour tenter de
suspendre cette entreprise en sachant
que la réaction de l'entreprise quand
elle se présente c'est qu'en est-il d'un
chantier parmi tant d'autres et la
sécurité n'a pas forcément été mise en
question c'est la performance donc la
difficulté c'est qu'on rentre finalement
au frontal avec des entreprises alors
que nous nous faisons appel à des
sous-traitants pour ces audits de
performance parce que ce n'est pas notre
métier de faire de l'audit ni du
contrôle de réalisation et qu'encore une
fois l'auditeur quand il est sur site il
ne peut que constater la misère mais en
tout cas il ne peut pas il ne peut rien
faire d'autre et il ne peut pas empêcher
l'entreprise de continuer d'agir le
consuel à la possibilité dans ces audits
dans ces contrôles de
la sécurité de dire
prochain prochain chantier
automatiquement contrôler ce que ce que
l'on ne peut pas faire dans cette partie
audit de performance donc on pourrait
peut-être réfléchir à une évolution de
cette mission le parallèle avec la
réalité autoconsommation est
intéressante le parallèle avec le décret
Hierve où là effectivement vous avez une
seule association qui pilote le
programme des C2E vous avez une
association qui encadrent les programmes
de formation vous avez ensuite les
centres de formation qui établissent et
qui constituent leur propre programme de
formation selon le cadre mais surtout
selon leur population de professionnels
parce que c'est important qu'un centre
de formation puisse délivrer une
formation qui correspondent aux attendus
de sa population et vous avez ensuite un
organisme de qualification Qualifelec
qui va agréer ses centres de formation
mais pour la qualification qualife
juste je voulais rajouter alors on
souhaite fait du contrôle de conformité
électrique ça c'est son métier de base
il a mis il travaille pour nous
également peut-être le contrôle des
installations
photovoltaïques sur le cadre du contrôle
de performance au sens j'aurais mis les
modules fast Nord ou avec des ombrages
etc nous ça nous est rapporté comme un
écart majeur et on est quand on reçoit
ce rapport on peut suspendre entre une
monnaie qu'elle le mettent dans les
règles dollars c'est parfois possible et
si elle le fait pas elle est suspendue
donc le rapport que fait construire
quand il nous remonte de la non
performance constaté on agit derrière et
une entreprise de sommets de faire que
l'installation elle soit performante et
si elle n'est pas elle saura suspendue
et pour un peu accéder de nouveau
à l'arrêter tarifaire
installation prévue par la radiateur
très bien monsieur rapporteur
et après sinon collègues ont des
questions à poser qui n'hésitent pas
juste peut-être un
remarque et puis une question une
question complémentaire non par rapport
à ce que vous disiez c'est vrai que sur
les trois sur le fait que
en tout cas vous dans vos contrôles oui
vous avez des résultats qui sont plutôt
très bons quoi et effectivement se
décalage par rapport à ce qu'on peut
on peut entendre ou percevoir en tout
cas et puis et puis du coup cette
réalité des contrôles c'est vrai quand
on avait auditionné
Lana
nous disait que je crois que c'était
quoi 10% en fait de des réalisations qui
étaient qui étaient contrôlées
j'ai pu en tête le
pourcentage en tout cas de non
conformité ou en tout cas de travaux qui
n'étaient pas qui était pas adaptés mais
c'était quand même important en tout cas
il nous signaler que c'était quand même
quelque chose qui était important et que
le fait que c'est vrai qu'il contrôlait
que 10% vraiment sur site parce qu'il
contrôle sur sur document mais vraiment
sur site et que quand même leurs
résultats et leur retour étaient quand
même pas si satisfaisant que ça quoi
donc voilà votre avis sur ce sur ce
décalage en tout cas de perception et
puis un autre un autre point c'est vrai
qu'on travaille pas mal aussi donc sur
sur cette commission d'enquête
sur l'évolution sur la question des
matériaux sur la question des filières
et notamment sur les questions des
matériaux biosourcés
réfléchir notamment sur des matériaux
plus locaux et ce voilà et donc ça veut
dire Nord etc nouvelle qualification
formation aussi des entreprises sur ces
nouveaux matériaux et donc savoir
comment vous vous intégriez cet aspect
là quoi parce que c'est vrai que j'ai
pas quelqu'un qui va faire
l'isolation en paille en chanvre enfin
sur d'autres matériaux de ce type de ce
type là est-ce que du coup vous
réfléchissez en tout cas un rg qui
serait spécifiquement adapté justement à
ces matériaux biosourcés est-ce que ça
existe déjà d'ailleurs je sais pas
mais en tout cas comment vous intégrer
en tout cas cette cette évolution qui
quoi qu'il en soit paré importante quand
on va si on veut monter en charge sur la
question de l'isolation thermique
je voudrais aussi
rappeler rechercheite donc je prends
lorsque je vais jusqu'à présent
j'utilise les services de caliba
gratuitement qu'est-ce que je vais
chercher je vais chercher une entreprise
qui est en règle alors je vais vous dire
quelles sont les choses qu'on demande à
une entreprise après vous me direz
qu'est-ce qu'on peut enlever pour
simplifier puisque tout le monde parle
de simplification on lui demande d'avoir
une inscription enregis des métiers
minimum un code Insee
une attestation d'inscription aux
cotisations URSSAF en régulière
une attestation d'assurance RC RC
décennale c'est ce que je demande donc
en général de toute façon une
attestation d'afficide d'affiliation à
jour à la caisse de congés payés du
bâtiment ça veut dire que c'est des
entreprises du bâtiment
et ensuite des informations
complémentaires déclaratives qui permet
d'apprécier l'activité économique de
l'entité chiffre d'affaires montant de
la sous-traitance qui est un sujet aussi
content de la sous-traitance les moyens
humains et le matériel voilà ce qu'on
demande sur la partie administrative
sur la partie technique on va lui
demander
on va lui demander de nous apporter les
exigences métiers qu'on peut exiger
c'est-à-dire son diplôme sa formation
les effectifs les chantiers de référence
les devis et factures les notes de
dimensionnement qui permettent
d'apprécier le métier en fait et que ces
éléments là vont être appréciés par
justement les professionnels puisque
c'est la nfx5091 qui fait que justement
cette
qualification est attribuée par les
Pères et pour le RGE on a un signe RGE
qui est attribué par siret comme je
disais tout à l'heure une exigence de
formation feebab ou NR et puis un
contrôle de réalisation qu'est-ce qu'on
peut enlever pour simplifier la chose
pas grand chose si on enlève quoi que ce
soit je vois pas quelle responsabilité
on pourrait avoir en disant bah oui ben
on va leur demander quoi en moins en
administratif et puis de savoir un
métier donc ça ça remet les choses en
place aussi par rapport à au brouhaha
sur simplification du rg celui qui n'est
pas capable de fournir ça moi en tant
qu'architecte je le prends pas c'est le
minimum qu'on peut attendre
des références donc
comment on peut améliorer ça
je pense que il y a déjà le fait que les
contrôles que nous faisons sont
suffisamment
probants par contre il y a un travail à
faire sur les échos délinquance ça oui
c'est cela qui pourrit c'est
effectivement la réputation du du singe
aujourd'hui une entreprise doit nous
fournir 5 références de chantier mais
une entreprise
artisanale de 0 à 5 ou à 10 qui fait 20
chantiers par an de
quel que soit des poêles à bois par
exemple ou autre
et bien il va me donner cinq chantiers
une entreprise
qui a 5000 chantiers va me donner 5
chantiers aussi est-ce logique
bah il y a un sujet
d'autre part si on a accès à l'ensemble
des chantiers et on l'a demandé à la
dette de nous mettre en commun cette
base de données de l'ensemble des
chantiers déclarés parce que c'est
effectivement là dedans qu'on devra
piocher ça nous donne le volume par
entreprise ça nous permet aussi d'aller
de dimensionner aussi des audits en
fonction de ça
or il y a un problème qui nous a été
soulevé par l'ADEM sur la propriété des
données personnelles le rgpd c'est ça
qui bloque aujourd'hui si on lève ce
verrou là et bien on aura une donnée
commune pour toutes nos entreprises et
on peut aller piocher et les auditer sur
la chantier tandis que là aujourd'hui on
est on est coincé par les cinq chantiers
qui ont déclarés qui sont dans le décret
c'est pas nous qui dit qui décidons ça
c'est le décret
et quand on parlait aussi des audits la
complexité des audits on a des audits
qui sont qui ont été décédés dans le
décret la grille d'audit elle est dans
le décret c'est pas nous qui décidons et
il y a une différence effectivement de
complétude du contrôle parce qu'on nous
les avons élaborés avec justement la DHP
et la DGC c'est grido dit pour avoir une
bonne vision et avec les professionnels
bien entendu pour avoir une bonne vision
de la qualité du travail des contrôles
ces deux œufs ça n'a rien à voir c'est
pas du tout le même objectif
l'objectif du C2E c'est de voir j'ai le
bon le bon isolant et j'ai la bonne
surface et mes contrôlent pas les écarts
au feu par exemple et donc on peut avoir
des conséquences importantes et il y en
a eu sur l'incendie de certains de
certains bâtiments donc c'est pas du
tout les mêmes objectifs nous on a
un contrôle de la qualité des travaux
tandis que le C2E ont un contrôle de la
conformité par rapport à un certain
nombre de critères qui sont beaucoup
plus réduits que les nôtres
que parmi de collègues oui Laurent
saumon
mais ton micro il rentre
est-ce qu'ils ont la possibilité d'avoir
accès justement à aux entreprises qui
sont qualifiées qualibates Qualifelec ou
kaliénaire première question
on envoie la base de données nous
quotidiennement je sais pas qualiférer
aussi ou qualiténaire aussi ces mises à
jour tous les jours
de où se renseigner pour pouvoir
consulter si les entreprises qui les
sollicitent comme vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure avec notamment les échos
délinquants
s'ils sont véritablement ce qu'on peut
avoir très bien l'estampis sur son
estafettes je veux dire ça c'est facile
à imiter on reçoit des courriers
internet de la même manière donc c'était
ma première question donc a priori c'est
possible il y a France rénover compris
la deuxième c'était vous dites dans les
entreprises générales mais Guillaume
Gantin a posé un petit peu mais il va
vouloir une précision dans une
entreprise générale il y a l'obligation
donc il y a une qualification par métier
donc vous vous audiez vous vérifiez que
chacun des métiers charpentier maçon que
sais-je et bien a bien la certification
Qualibat pour chacune des professions
oui la qualification est par métier donc
si c'est une entreprise générale elle va
avoir
10 15 20 qualifications et si elle a une
activité pour lesquelles les épates
qualifiés elle va sous-traiter à une
entreprise qui elle est RGE et qualifiée
pour cette activité
parce que vous avez dit un référent
qualité quelle est sa quelle est sa
composition j'allais dire en tout cas
quel est son rôle et qu'elle est c'est
ses qualités alors il y a il y a deux
choses il y a le référent technique et
le référent RGE le référent RGE c'est
celui qui a eu la formation
correspondant donc soit je suis dans le
domaine de l'isolation et la chaudière
et à ce moment-là c'est une formation
feebab qui a suivi cette personne et
c'est cette personne qui normalement est
sur le chantier soit je suis dans le
domaine des énergies renouvelables et à
ce moment là j'ai une formation pack si
j'ai le un signe RGE pack j'ai une
formation chaudière bois si j'ai un
signe nerveux chaudière bois j'ai une
formation qui est adaptée en fonction de
la catégorie de travaux
le référent technique c'est celui qui
détient la compétence métier et qui va
être analysé par un comité de
qualification de professionnels
d'experts le référent RGE c'est celui
qui a fait la formation et la formation
elle est spécifique par par typologie de
NR ou effectivement dans l'efficacité
énergétique c'est une formation globale
fibatrice qui est en cours de de
révision
beaucoup de qualité énerve un référent
technique ou RGE c'est le même c'est
celui qui a la compétence dans la
filière renouvelable dans lequel elle
suscité la qualification
qui doit avoir réussi sa formation
professionnelle et que l'entreprise par
ailleurs respectent ensemble des
exigences d'un point de vue assurance
ciel métier etc je voulais juste
rebondir sur la question de Monsieur
gondin sur le la différence entre le
stade de Lana de non conformité est-ce
que nous on peut rencontrer côté NR on
serait assez intéressé dans les stades
de la NAS spécifiquement sur les travaux
d'énergie renouvelables parce que il y a
pas la même notion de nombre de travaux
d'isolation etc de changement de fenêtre
par rapport à spécificité des chantiers
au MR qui est une base plus restreinte
entre guillemets et sur la notion de
filière les énergies renouvelables sont
pas aujourd'hui strictoens concerné par
cette notion de déco matériaux par
contre il y aurait une vraie réflexion à
avoir sur cette notion de fil Ière sur
nos besoins de ressources humaines
on a besoin d'ici 2025 de 20000
installateurs solaires on les forme où
quand avec qui et ça aujourd'hui si on
veut réussir la transition et cette
accélération de la transition on a
besoin de compétences
qui viendront grandir les forces de nos
entreprises
moi je voudrais peut-être pour calibat
parce que vous nous avez précisé le
nombre d'entreprises qui donc
le nombre d'audites plutôt 8% de disques
que vous avez considéré comme étant non
conforme est-ce que vous pourriez nous
donner les chiffres à partir de ces
audits qui ont considéré comme non
conforme le chiffre des entreprises qui
ont pu être radiées
ou suspendus
alors une entreprise qui est un non
conformité elle va être suspendue dans
la foulée dans la foulée dans la foulée
il va y avoir un deuxième audit qui va
être déclenché
sur un autre chantier pour voir si le
cas qui a été examiné et récurrent ou si
c'est une erreur à un moment donné voilà
et après la décision l'ensemble des
rapports va être passé devant la
commission d'examen et c'est la
commission d'examen qui va procéder au
retrait de la qualification ou en
demandant à au référents ou responsables
techniques de faire une mise à niveau en
terme de formation mais par exemple sur
l'année 2022 est-ce que vous avez
le chiffrage des entreprises qui ont été
finalement radiées suspendus après avoir
eu un premier contrôle puis un deuxième
dans le cadre de du processus
d'accord et le fait que parce que les
entreprises elles ont la liberté de
s'adresser à qualifierlec à
kalibataire donc voilà c'est une liberté
totale est-ce que pour vous c'est
susceptible d'entraîner des risques de
distorsion ou est-ce que vous délivrez
vous vous accréditation et vos
qualifications dans le même temps est-ce
qu'elle pourrait être tenter
d'identifier l'un des trois parmi vous
parce que la créditation la
certification et la qualification serait
donnée plus rapidement
oui l'entreprise peut s'adresser
indifféremment ou aux uns aux autres
après on n'a pas de base de données
communes que nous partageons entre
organismes de qualification pour savoir
si l'entreprise est qualifiée chez Intel
ou chez Intel et de même si on lui
retire le signe et le quel est le motif
du retrait du signe et est-ce qu'il y a
des entreprises qui ont pu être chez
kalibat puis changer
aller chez un autre
éventuellement il y a les arguments ou
les motifs qui sont donnés à ce
moment-là ou je sais pas quand elles
viennent voir un deuxième organisme
comme vous en vous disant ben voilà moi
j'étais jusqu'à présent chez kalibat je
viens chez vous est-ce que est-ce qu'il
y a des motifs qui sont donnés ou est-ce
que pas du tout ou vous voulez demander
pas forcément
bon déjà la première chose c'est que
tous les organismes de qualification
posent pas tous les domaines oui donc en
réalité ce jeu de d'aller d'un organisme
à l'autre ça peut vite s'arrêter puisque
par exemple sur l'isolation calibat
sur les domaines où il y a une
concurrence effectivement il pourrait y
avoir cette tentation d'aller à un
organisme à l'autre
s'il a été si a fait l'objet de sanction
néanmoins si alors pour les sanctions
liées aux audits il y a peu de
communication aujourd'hui en tout cas
pour les sanctions liées à
l'échoderlinquance et j'imagine que
derrière votre question c'est ça qui se
cache
il y a des communications qui sont
faites entre les organismes de
qualification sur les les entreprises
qui sont
identifiées comme écoute délinquante et
qu'on fait l'objet de sanctions
notamment les radiations pour informer
des mesures fortes qui ont été prises
vis-à-vis d'un certain public bon ça
reste des volumes qui sont très faibles
comparativement aux sanctions qui
peuvent être prises dans le cadre des
de Qualibat mais qualité-preneur je
regardais dans le cadre du rapport
transmis au ministère l'état des lieux
par rapport aux qualifications donc en
2022 c'est
c'est plus de 1500 suspensions qui ont
été notifiés suite à des écarts
constatés après l'audit et sur ces 1500
l'état des lieux au 29 mars 347 était
encore active donc on voit qu'on a quand
même des entreprises ben voilà qui sont
suspendues parce qu'elles n'ont pas
corrigé assez vite les défauts mais font
cette démarche de corriger les défauts
et donc ça veut dire aussi qu'une fois
qu'on est passé on a des installations
qui fonctionnent mieux que si on n'était
pas passé au moins dans ce cas là pour
1200 en 2022 ça veut dire aussi que ceux
qui ne font pas cet effort là sont
suspendus et donc perdre leur label RJ
en tout cas chez nous et voici le monde
à ce petit jeu là rapidement de manière
générale puisque
peu de qualifications qui qui sont tous
les organismes en même temps
j'ai encore une question est peut-être
après bien sûr monsieur le rapporteur
Bruno Le Maire a annoncé alors j'ai pu
les chiffres exacts en tête mais que à
l'horizon 2025 c'est peut-être 200 000
entre 250 000 entreprises 250
000 entreprises RGE est-ce que vous
pensez que ces crédible et que voilà qui
la volonté ou l'ambition de mais est-ce
que vous pensez concrètement c'est très
court 2025 c'est demain aujourd'hui on
en a combien vous nous rappelez le
chiffre
globale si on additionne tous nos
chiffres on doit être à peu près à 70
000 d'accord donc c'est colossal quand
même donc en l'espace de grosso modo un
peu moins de deux ans pour vous ça vous
semble réaliste mais au plus fort du RGE
au plus fort du RGE c'est en 2017
on avait à peu près 90 000
professionnels mais entité
professionnelle RJ si nous aujourd'hui
du côté kalibat on en a 45000 ça
représente plus de 550
000 salariés
donc des bras il y a un certain volume
de bras
d'ailleurs les entreprises en 2020
on fait plus de travaux
qu'elles n'en faisait en 2017 alors
qu'il y avait plus de professionnels RG
donc il y a peut-être cette notion de
quelle est la mobilisation des
effectifs dans l'activité rénovation
aujourd'hui aussi voilà donc il y a il y
a mais après il y aura la question qui a
été sauvée tout à l'heure qui est aussi
de la formation de l'accompagnement de
la montée en compétences
pour compléter je peux donner aussi des
chiffres puisqu'on en est là dedans on a
pour les entreprises qualifiées chez
kalibats 821
000 salariés
sur un million de
200000 donc on a quand même 69 %
des salariés des entreprises sont
qualifiées chez nous chiffre d'affaires
global 140 milliards et des brouettes
sur 150 milliards pour le BTP
donc les entreprises aujourd'hui qui
sont chez nous
ça représente quand même une très grande
majorité des acteurs
après vous nous dites d'affirmer ou non
la volonté d'un ministre on va pas se
permettre
on l'a croisé dans le hall quand même
par contre
on a
pris les mesures pour ce dimensionner
pour ça au sein de qualitatif en tout
cas oui on a entendu
président Macron on a entendu Monsieur
le Maire Monsieur le Ministre et bien
dès qu'on a entendu ça quand on est
rentré Kléber je peux vous dire
après si l'objectif c'est 250000 oui
notre travail c'est de se dimensionner
pour ça après le recrutement c'est pas
que nous
juste un chiffre
vous disiez tout à l'heure que
l'effectif des RGE il était sur le
rapporteur aussi stable ou même à la
perte il faut savoir que la perte de
professionnelle RGE ce sont sur les
petites entités c'est les entités de
moins de 5 salariés
les entités de plus de 20 salariés sont
vraiment stables voire même viennent
vers le RGE alors qu'il n'était pas hier
parce que ce sont des entreprises d'une
certaine taille c'est les entreprises
qui généralement ont la démarche d'aller
vers la qualification métier puisque on
est plutôt dans une approche B2B et non
pas vers les travaux de particulier donc
par exemple aujourd'hui des entreprises
de vin salariés qui font de l'étanchéité
viennent vers le RGE parce qu'elles font
de la rénovation de copro
alors qu'elle ne le faisait pas
nécessairement hier donc sur cette
population là on va dire que le taux de
pénétration de la qualification est plus
significatif et en même temps plus haut
où nous avons des difficultés c'est
effectivement sur les petites
entreprises qui sont aussi sujettes au
fluctuations des aides nous avons eu de
plein plein d'exemples en fin de l'année
fin de l'année dernière où nous avons
effectivement beaucoup de chauffagistes
qui ont arrêté le signe de du RGE
chaudière puisqu'il y a plus d'aide sur
les chaudières donc du coup le
chauffagiste qui est toute énergie il
faut qu'il soit capable de répondre à
diverses choses il va garder son
Seigneur géopathe mais le Seigneur géo
chaudière il va l'abandonner
par exemple sur les fenêtres on a eu un
reflux au moment où il y a une baisse de
la prise en charge de changement de
fenêtre et on a un apport maintenant un
afflux d'entreprise parce que les
clients le demandent le Seigneur je même
si les aides ont été baissées donc ça
montre aussi la valeur de ce de ce label
monsieur le rapporteur
la comparaison avec l'Allemagne
parce que c'est vrai que si on écoute le
ministre qui dit qu'il faut aller en
gros vraiment une massification en fait
du RGE du coup se pose la question de se
dire est-ce qu'il faudrait pas le rendre
obligatoire quoi c'est-à-dire est-ce que
le fait qu'on ait des qualifications
plus poussées en fait pour chaque pour
chaque entreprise qui fait que ben voilà
pour s'installer que ça soit en
isolation en électricité voilà qu'on est
ce minimum en fait de de formation qui
permettent ensuite de pas avoir ce cet
aspect là de dire je choisis et je enfin
voilà on sait que on fait appel à une
entreprise elle a deux faites parce
qu'elle a installé cette qualification
quoi qu'est-ce que vous pensez
que pour la lecture à la fois pour le
particulier pour les entreprises aussi
il faudrait qu'il y ait qu'un seul signe
RGE plutôt que d'avoir RGE c'est Dee ma
prime Réno parce que pour certains
chantiers on peut avoir le cumul des
trois pour le même sentier pour la même
entreprise ce qui est absurde quand même
donc si on avait le plus complet c'est
le contrôle c'est les audite RGE prenons
ce cet audit-là qui soit la référence
maintenant pour les contrôles pour
l'ensemble pour l'audit pour l'ensemble
des opérations ça va aussi nettoyer un
peu le paysage dans l'esprit à la fois
des entreprises et des et des clients
finaux
oui c'était juste pour dire nous dans le
domaine des énergies renouvelables on
voit absolument pas de régression mais
une croissance constante et y compris
des petites entreprises qui loin de se
détourner des qualifications dans le
domaine des aménageurs nobles ils
viennent on va vers de la
malédicification de développement des
énergies renouvelables
ça veut dire que la maman aussi on aura
un marché qui sera vraisemblablement
plus aidé parce que c'est aussi la fin
du quoi qu'il en coûte qui sera moins
aidé et finalement c'est comment est-ce
qu'on pilote un marché avec une
régulation un peu naturelle et
aujourd'hui celui qui pourra peut-être
demander la qualification c'est le
banquier
parce que lui finance des travaux et
pour que le ménage rembourse il faut
qu'il les économies et donc faut que
l'installation moi je parle d'un point
de vue OMR elle rend le service pour
lequel elle a été prévue parce que si
elle rend pas le service c'est une
facture d'énergie qui augmente et
quelqu'un qui peut pas payer son prêt
donc peut-être que demain la régulation
de la qualification de l'entreprise dans
un marché mature ça s'appelle le
banquier ça s'appelle l'assureur parce
que si je fais installer une
installation photovoltaïque par un
professionnel qui est pas RGE qu'est-ce
qui peut arriver à ma maison est-ce que
j'ai un risque incendie est-ce que j'ai
un risque électrique voilà alors que si
c'est géré par un professionnel qualifié
RGE le sueur et le banquiers sont plutôt
rassurés donc c'est un peu c'est les
exigences il va falloir qu'on essaie
aussi ça veut dire quoi on présente les
résultats d'audit moi je milite pour
qu'on partage nos résultats d'audits sur
le photovoltaïque depuis 2017 on est une
entreprise une secteur sous surveillance
donc on a un audit tous les 14
installations
un moment ça fait 6 ans on pourrait se
dire qu'est-ce qu'on a mesuré en termes
d'évolution de qualité quand est-ce que
les assureurs vont prendre en compte
cette sonde systématique parce
qu'aujourd'hui il regarde pas nos
résultats d'audites et nous disent ouais
mais on a des sinistres qui datent des
matériels qui ont été installés avant
2017 donc étant intégré bâti aujourd'hui
ça n'existe quasiment plus l'intégrature
que du surimposer et vu qu'il regarde
dans le rétroviseur sans regarder la
jauge du présent ah vous êtes quand même
un secteur c'est compliqué ça coûte cher
de s'assurer voir on vous assure pas
donc voilà c'est il y a des choses à
prendre en compte mais c'est on a ce
travail à faire avec le secteur bancaire
le secteur assurantiel pour qu'il se
dise un professionnel qui est compétent
dans son domaine RGE on peut lui faire
confiance pour financer les travaux
est-ce que ces secteurs montrent
aujourd'hui de la frilosité de la
volonté
le secteur
assurantiel réassurera pleinement le
solaire après 2027 en mai je peux même
vous donner la date presque le jour
parce que en fait ils ont le risque de
décennales qui s'applique sur tous les
matériels qui étaient en intégrisme
avant 2017 non seulement n'importe qui
pouvait faire n'importe quoi dans le
domaine solaire mais en plus c'était
obligé de casser son toit pour faire de
l'intégrer bâti résultat il y a des
désordres qui arrivent 4 5 6 ans 8 ans
après depuis 2017 on fait l'intégrer sur
imposé bâti donc tous les risques sont
ultra limités et donc on est plus sur
les mêmes technologies mais eux
considèrent encore les pathologies de
l'ancienne techno donc passer mai 2027
ils auront purgé le risque décennale et
ils sont très enclins assurer le secteur
dans votre devoir d'apporter un service
à nous qualifier
on n'a pas on a développé un partenariat
avec l'essma BTP qui dansait
évaluations de risque lorsqu'une
entreprise vient lui demander une une
assurance décennale intègre dans sa
cotation le fait qu'il soit qualifié ou
non
donc il a une réduction il a une qui
n'apparaît pas sur la prime mais dans
son la prime est calculée par rapport à
ça donc ça c'est un élément aussi
important vis-à-vis de nos qualifiés et
d'autre part qui montre aussi que selon
l'assureur le fait d'être qualifié à une
valeur pour lui sur les risques
non j'avais une dernière mais vraiment
pour être
très précis dans le principe justement
de qualification enfin en gros je suis
entreprise de d'isolation thermique
comment ça se passe vraiment
qu'est-ce que je dois fournir bon j'ai
vu l'ensemble des documents en termes de
chantier faire le contrôle se fait sur
quoi et comment pour obtenir en fait mon
label RGE je suis une nouvelle
entreprise je m'installe et comment ça
se passe
donc je vais pas revenir sur l'aspect de
l'ensemble des documents je précise
quand même que les documents aujourd'hui
on est partenaire MPS donc marché public
simplifié et donc on peut aller chercher
la data directement auprès des services
de l'État donc demain on ne demande plus
les Urssaf on va chercher sinon
l'entreprise et à jour de ses URSSAF
donc la partie on va dire administrative
est en train d'être
allégé avec cette possibilité d'aller
chercher directement les données et ça
c'est ça c'est important
après évidemment ça va être surtout sur
la partie technique ou là l'entreprise
doit tout simplement nous prouver
qu'elle a les compétences le
savoir-faire le matériel et les hommes
pour pouvoir réaliser des chantiers en
isolation thermique par l'extérieur par
exemple donc on va lui demander des
références de chantier on va lui
demander des attestations de travaux
signés par des clients on va lui
demander des devis des factures on va
lui demander les fiches techniques des
produits mises en oeuvre ou on va lui
demander la liste de son personnel
qu'elle est depuis quand quel est leur
classification le responsable technique
qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure où le
directeur technique quel est son CV
quelles sont ses diplômes et on va
inventorier l'ensemble des des moyens et
matériels et humains et des réalisations
faites par l'entreprise et c'est ça qui
va être examiné par la commission
d'examen qui est donc avec tous les
acteurs du secteur et qui va dire oui on
lui donne non lui donne pas donc du coup
sur cette phase donc là après ensuite il
a son RGE donc sur cette phase là il y a
pas de contrôle sur site quoi non il y a
juste des références de chantier et des
exactement et après il a donc nous
déclarer nous dans les six mois qui
suivent l'attribution du signe puisqu'on
doit faire un contrôle sur 24 mois on va
s'adresser à l'entreprise on va lui dire
déclarer le nouveau chantier voilà les
fameux cinq chantiers à minima à doux
déclarer et on va en choisir un sur
lequel on va défaire l'audit ce qui veut
dire que sur les 5 c'est lui qui va
donner 5 chantiers c'est lui qui donne 5
chantiers ça revient sur ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure c'est c'est la
donnée qui pour nous est essentielle si
on avait les retours des contrôles Anna
si on avait les retours des contrôles
des obligés
on aurait une visibilité autre sur les
professionnels énergies et aujourd'hui
on ne l'a pas si on avait la base de
données communes de tous les chantiers
aidés nous pourrions aller chercher
aléatoirement les chantiers et c'est
d'ailleurs comme ça que nous arrivons à
sortir des économies c'est parce que ils
ont fait 5000 chantiers dans l'année on
leur demande leur CRM on leur demande
une liste de chantiers on les choisit
aléatoirement et on choisissant
aléatoirement sur ces 5000 chantiers ben
c'est pas de chance on va faire 5 audit
sur 5 chantiers différents et sur chaque
chantier il y a des non conformités avec
des écarts majeurs mettant parfois en
péril la vie des occupants
du coup sur le contrôle enfin sur les
sur les les cinq les cinq chantiers
c'est sur ce que vous disiez sur le fait
que c'est 5 si c'est une petite
entreprise qui fait Didi chantiers
parents et une qui en fait 4000 du coup
vous verrez l'évolution comment est-ce
que par exemple le fait de dire que
c'est des chantiers aléatoires qui sont
contrôlés parce que c'est vrai que là
comme c'est un choix et donc forcément
ce choix là si c'est sur 4000 chantiers
c'est quand même un peu plus facile de
sélectionner des chantiers enfin voilà
ce que du coup cette évolution là vous
vous paraît souhaitable par exemple de
dire c'est 5 chantiers déjà de manière
aléatoire sur l'ensemble du parc ou
enfin comment vous imaginez l'évolution
en tout cas par rapport à ce que vous
disiez
c'est sûr qu'il faut dimension il faut
dimensionner au volume alors que dans le
décret on n'a pas ça donc c'est ça qu'il
faut introduire effectivement c'est en
fonction du volume mais pour pouvoir
avoir ce volume là il faut avoir la base
de données effectivement commune de
déclaration puisqu'ils vont chercher des
des aides forcément c'est dans un dans
une base de données c'est cette base de
données qui doit être partagée avec les
organismes de qualification qui nous
permettra d'une part de dimensionner et
de voir comment faire évoluer le décret
on est prêt à discuter avec avec les
services de l'État là-dessus et puis en
fonction de ces de ces dimensionnement
on ira piocher dans cette base de
données à ce moment-là on a toute
liberté de de pouvoir renforcer les
contrôles de pouvoir cibler les
contrôles aussi dès le moment on a des
signalements et puis d'autre part la la
commission comment on appelle la
commission de coordination la différence
des différents organisations avec la
DGCCRF avec la gendarmerie etc il faut
qu'on échange là-dessus parce que
aujourd'hui la DGCCRF elle nous signale
pas elle nous dit pas voilà telle
entreprise à tel endroit non elle ne dit
rien donc ça c'est des choses à échanger
pour l'heure c'est non
otite au nom de la rgpd
on peut avoir aussi une requête d'un
procureur on peut avoir
la gendarmerie qui se rend même dans une
agence Qualibat pour demander à faire
les photocopies des pièces qui sont
entre nos mains pour voir comment le
synergies et sur la base de quels
documents le synerge a été livré donc on
a de la collaboration mais on aimerait
mieux aider
à conduire avec le pnc2e pour exploiter
soit directement soit indirectement leur
base de données qui sont les clients
finaux comme demander de l'aide réaliser
quels travaux par quelle entreprise ça
c'est nous une entreprise qui nous
déclare pas des travaux on peut pas
aller faire des audits quand on connaît
pas le client final
alors soit
rgpd pourrait nous permettre de nous
donner pas toute la base mais un extrac
de clients et entre guillemets on
pourrait également travailler avec qui
sont les gros faiseurs parce que
finalement il y a des entreprises qui
font énormément de ces deux oeufs et
puis on en a plein qui en font un petit
peu donc sur ces gros faiseurs on n'a
pas besoin d'avoir leurs 4000 clients
mais si nous faisait un extract de 50
chantiers alors pendant contrôler 5 ça
nous donnerait déjà une base
on travaille pas à RGB ou alors
peut-être c'est que le les audits de C2E
deviennent des audite RGE ils se mettent
au même niveau de contrôle et il nous
donne le résultat qu'on puisse nous
communiquer des choses
[Musique]
ou bien moi j'ai quand même le sentiment
que on demande aux délégataires et aux
obliger de faire quelque chose qui n'est
pas tout à fait dans leur ADN à savoir
faire des contrôles alors même on a des
organismes de qualification donc c'est
la mission de vérifier que l'entreprise
a les moyens voir au travers des audits
réalise correctement ces chantiers et
effectivement si on avait accès à plus
facilement à la donnée sur les clients
finaux
ce qu'on a déjà partiellement
aujourd'hui on a déjà des accords avec
le pnc2e mais sur des volumes qui sont
qui sont faibles en termes
d'échantillonnages on pourrait comme
cela existe sur le photovoltaïque comme
cela existe sur le forage de jeu pour le
jeu thermique de minimum important
en ayant accès à cette donnée là faire
les contrôles qui sont aujourd'hui fait
par d'autres organismes et encore une
fois par en interne puisque de toute
façon c'est sous-traiter à des
organismes compétents à la matière ils
organismes de contrôle mais l'avantage
de les faire dans nos organismes de
qualification c'est que on a cette
capacité de sanction que non pas
nécessairement les obliger les
délégataires où il est très bien que si
on a des cartons rouges qui sont sortis
par Qualibat qualife Kate NR ça peut
très rapidement mettre en jeu un écho
délinquant ce qui est plus difficile
pour les objets délicataires qui
finalement se repasse la patate chaude
en disant bon ben voilà je travaille
plus avec vous allez voir il va aller
voir quelqu'un d'autre et intéressant
que nous nous ayons l'information
que le professionnel se comporte mal
donc effectivement il y aurait peut-être
un intérêt à simplifier les démarches
puisque pour l'entreprise il y aurait
qu'un interlocuteur par rapport au
contrôle un interlocuteur qui a connu et
coordonnées ces contrôles pour faire en
sorte que quand il y a des écarts ils
soient corrigés à ma connaissance et pas
d'obligation de correction en tout cas
pas de contrôle sur le terrain quand il
y a des écarts majeurs dans le cas du
c2o avec des réserves mais ce que j'ai
cru comprendre
ce qui n'est pas le cas pour les années
de qualification il y a des
contrevisitres qui sont réalisées et en
cas de problématique on a cette capacité
de sanction non pas nécessairement nos
camarades
je pense que il y a peut-être
effectivement l'intérêt de redistribuer
les cartes pour fluidifier un peu les
choses et améliorer
la qualité des audits qui sont faits et
les suites qui sont données en cas de
malfaçon
bien écoutez je vous remercie de ces
échanges qui ont été très très
intéressants merci beaucoup madame et
messieurs si vous avez des éléments que
nous n'aurions pas abordé de vive voix
et que vous souhaitez par rapport au
questionnaire que vous avez pu recevoir
nous donner un syndrome de précision
n'hésitez pas à les faire remonter vers
l'administration de la commission
d'enquête et on vous souhaite une bonne
fin de journée merci beaucoup merci